hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
I hope you're doing well and in today's
video what I'll be talking about is the
orderflow point of control now some
people refer to it as well as um the co
or commitment of Traders however you
know most people refer to it as point of
control but if you see the word or the
phrase coot or commitment of Traders um
it also refers to to to uh point of
control now don't get that confused with
the uh commitment of Traders report that
comes out from the government which is
you the positioning thing what we're
talking about is in the order flow so
what is point of control well it's the
price level in a bar with the most
volume now every bar is going to have a
point of control and it's just a simple
mathematical formula where you take the
volume traded on the bid the volume
traded on the offer and if it's the
level price level with the most volume
that's what it is okay so you can see
here on this red bar down here 4045 this
is the price level with the most volume
you got 145 traded on the bid 125 traded
on the
offer on this green bar the point of
control is at 40 46 and a half it's got
118 traded on the bid 157 traded on the
offer now it's calculated at a price
level it's not calculated in the two-way
auction now like I said every bar will
have a point of control now some
software I know my software does it and
many other ones do it does actually give
you the ability if you would like to add
on on PC2 PC3 which would be you know
the second most price sorry the second
most volume in the bar and the third
most uh third price level with the most
volume in the bar so you can have you
know the most the second most and the
third most in a bar however you know for
most practical purposes for most Traders
just seeing the price level with the
most volume is enough you don't need to
really get down into the third level um
of volume and depending on the type of
chart that you're looking at you don't
need to get down into the third you know
if you're looking at a four range chart
you you only got five price levels do
you do you really need to see the second
price level with the most volume and the
third most volume price level no you
don't because you only got five levels
now couple things about point of
control yes every bar has one and
because of that sometimes people just
sort of disregard the point of control
because it's like ah you know every
Bar's got one and it's all jumping all
over the place I I can't make heads or
taals of it but when you're looking at
point of control you have to think in
terms of volume Now volume is relative
as well so you know it's just not about
what volume is doing in this bar you
also want to compare it to what volumes
are doing in the previous bars and
that's especially important with with
point of control because you want to see
where point of control is coming in as
price starts moving as you compare it to
the previous bar you know is price
moving higher is point of control moving
in the same direction and you know one
of the basic simplest things I like to
look for is in a trending Market
obviously volume is going to be moving
higher as a result point of controls are
going to be moving higher you want to
see in a trending upward Market you want
to see point of controls moving higher
along with price in a market that's
trending down you want to see point of
controls moving lower lower lower and
not by what I say lower lower
lower relative to the previous bars so
for example right here Cash open right
here a83 and you can see point of
control moving higher price moving
higher up up up you know as the market
is moving directionally you're going to
see point of controls going higher and
why is that as the market is trending up
the volume of trade should be going up
when you start seeing markets go
sideways you start to see point of
controls more or less going sideways
look at this sideways chop activity
right here okay so this was the Cash
open right here sort of hit this High
then all of a sudden point of controls
the volumes are sort of clumped in
together between you know basically 542
and you know 53 we got point of control
one two 3 four um you know five six
seven point of controls right around in
that little tight zone right in in that
consolidation period if you will even
though price obviously got a high of 7
and a qu a low of 50 know 49 and 3/4 but
more or less the volume the balance is
taking place right in this chop area
where majority of the point of controls
are occurring you know right in
here right so you could sort of Define a
little bit um on a granular level where
that sideways activity is is really
taking place now like I said one of the
things I like to look for in determining
if a market is trending up or trending
down is which direction the point of
controls are going along with price so
obviously if you're going to have a
trend you need to put in a bottom okay
so this was sort of this swing low right
ahead of the cash open and then Green
Bar Green Bar Green Bar you're seeing
point of control higher price is
obviously higher point of control higher
than the previous bar this point of
control is higher than the previous
bar point of control coming up here
obviously higher than the previous bar
Which is higher than the previous bar so
point of control you'd say is migrating
higher obviously price is you know
closing up around the point of controls
now where point of control lands in a
bar is kind of important now you know if
you're familiar with you know volume
profile Market profile you know the the
the standard distribution of a normal
day is his volume is kind of
concentrated around the midpoint of the
trading
day and in a bar it's it's kind of
similar too right you're going to have a
high you're going to have a low and you
know your normal day you know looking on
a bar is going to be sort of your
d-shaped now this point of control is
appearing right in the middle okay you
know it it's not positive it's not
negative it's just normal what I like to
see you know on a market that's starting
to move is point of controls coming in
somewhere up near the the upper end
right because it's telling me that
Traders are moving price higher and
there's more Traders or more trades
rather transacting at those higher
prices right that's what you want to see
on a market that's trending up is more
transactions taking place at higher
prices just as on a market that's
selling off you want to see more
transactions at lower and lower prices
because you know that Traders are
chasing price up or chasing price
down and you see we finally top out up
here at you know at 58th point of
control somewhere up near the top so
Traders were still chasing it higher but
then sort of the buying got shut off I'm
not going to talk about what shuts off
buying in this video and you can see the
market Dro right back down into this
area where you sort of had these
three-pointer controls right around the
same area is and then we're just sort of
rotating back and forth we push lower
right coming down to sort of our initial
balance low
here and what happens we trade more
volume down here right the point of
control is down here actually um just
eyeballing it I I would guess that this
next level right below it at at 4 and a
half is probably your point of control
to so I know that I'm getting a lot of
volume down here right at this sort of
initial balance low and that's holding
now when I see a lot of volume when I
see a bar like this right sort of just
pokes down you know sort of like this uh
what you call this is like a hammer
formation right which is sort of the
opposite of the star up here it's hard
to say a star because the body is kind
of big but it's similar but I'm seeing
the point of control coming in out here
or down here and point of control coming
up in here yeah it's telling me that you
know Traders were trying to push it or
you know the market was looking for new
levels to transact at obviously rejected
these levels there was strong buying
down here right to support this Market
point of controls down here when I see
point of controls down towards the
bottom of bars um you know as the market
pushes lower it's telling me there's
potential support there just as when I
see you know point of controls coming in
at higher levels up here like at uh this
one's coming at 57 it's telling me that
there's um some resistance up there
right because it's telling me there's
passive sellers up there that are
willing to absorb whatever buying is
taking place just as I got passive
buyers down here willing to absorb
whatever selling taking place and then
the market rotates back up into that
area where a lot of chop right now you
know as a Trader one of the things that
you always want to be doing is identify
you know areas where the market is
consolidating and that's something that
point of controls are going to help you
to see if you're starting to see point
of controls coming in you know more or
less you know in the same price area
right I mean you're not going to see
generally bars with like four or five
point of controls exactly at the same
price I mean you can i' I've seen it but
you know more or less within you know a
few ticks of each other is telling me
that you know this is an area where
people are happy to transact at and
their transactions aren't going to move
price very much right so you can see
here this one's coming at 57 and a
quarter or sorry 57 52 and 3/4 this is
53 and a quarter this is 53 um um you
know even earlier you're looking at 53
and a half down here is 52 and A4 Etc
and then you start seeing the sort of
the same things coming in here we're
sort of back in the zone that we
established earlier 53 and 3/4 um you
got one down here 52 and a qu here 52
and a half up here 53 and 3/4 um 53 and
a half but really what you're going to
start to look for is breaking out of
this area and we sort of broke out down
here put in some volume and rotate right
back in broke out again put in more
volume down here 49 a
half okay so we got the first little
potential breakout second little
potential breakout but then the next bar
we rotate right back in just like here
we rotate right back in now though we we
traversed all the way from you know sort
of the lowish area all the way up
through the upper end and now point of
control it went from below this
consolidation area to point of control
starting up here above the consolidation
area okay so what do you think that is
well it's probably bullish because
volume is now starting to migrate
higher then the next bar point of
control price is moving higher point of
control moving higher so already I've
got sort of this little swing low here a
higher point of control on the next bar
higher point of control than the
previous bar higher point of control
than the previous
bar and then we're going up towards the
high again higher point of control now
we pair up the point of controls right
here you can see this is coming in at 61
and A4 and then we start going higher so
we're sort of forming a little bit of a
base here now we've got two point of
controls coming in at the same price
level and when I started seeing point of
controls line up like that I'm I'm
looking as you know this could be a
potential I say ledge but a potential
spot that you know is forming
a im like a 2x4 you know a piece of wood
support the market if we're going to
trade above it you know I want to be
trading on the long side if we're going
to break this and come down yeah I'd be
looking to trade it on the downside and
obviously it just keeps going up Up and
Up start coming off we hit these new
highs now as we're hitting these highs
look at this difference between on this
rally up here all right we're getting
space space between the point of control
you know 7 and A4 of to 59 so that's um
just under two points 59 up to 61 and a
quarter again just time just over two
points so then a big gap here you know
61 and a quar up to 66 and a 3/4 so
about Five Points then as you're getting
up here point you know even though we're
going higher you just by a couple ticks
you see point of controls are sort of
Contracting then you get that push down
then point of controls sort of lining up
more or less I mean the average of these
five is probably right around here 66
and 3/4 but they're sort of bunched up
again so you know it's not uncommon to
see the market just had a nice rally up
point of control sort of bunching up in
here going sideways we do poke up again
you get that sort of probe up here you
get that point of control way up here
heavy volume that is being shut off by
the market and the market starts coming
back this area it's a bit choppy you
know you got the one two three point of
controls this one Higher Than This one
this one Higher Than This One and then
down here but then it drops down and
then we start going sideways again what
you're going to look for is what areas
where point of control is starting to
assert itself and you start to see it
right here right there's one two three
going higher you know if I was going to
trade this I'd be trading it from the
the long side in here now would I be
trading it from the short side off this
you know potentially because I've got
these two red bars point of control here
this lower point of control so I got two
side side by side um this one is coming
in lower okay but the next bar doesn't
go any doesn't go lower in fact it just
rallies right back up through these
points of controls so even though this
appears bearish on the surface and
followed by this bar here is bearish the
fact that we can't go any lower it's not
a good sign right so even if I was
bearish off that I got to turn
bullish because it's trading right
through this right because if you have
something that's bearish information and
the market isn't really reacting to it
then you got to be looking at going
towards the other side and the market
just uh continues back up right up to
new
highs so again you know point of control
it's an interesting piece of information
and I could go on and on about it which
I'll probably make a few more U videos
for you guys but you know you got to
start to think it in context of you know
what happened in the previous bar or
bars you know where the point of
controls is coming in relative to price
is price moving and is point of controls
moving right if if price looks like it's
moving up or down but point of controls
are more or less staying
static then you that's telling you
something so I hope you enjoy this video
be sure to like And subscribe to the
channel and we're constantly making new
videos out for you you
know point of control is um a very
interesting concept and you know in our
sort of a preview of our upcoming
upgrade on on our orderflow software
is the ability to really sort of draw
out point of controls as support or
resistance as as zones that you can
trade into so you know be on the lookout
for you know those videos that are going
to come out soon um we're still beta
testing the upgrade so I hope to uh see
you guys on the inside bye-bye